bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono pani j oggi
siamo su un video su rocket league
disavventure della mia vita a vele
racconto dei ragazzi oggi che serve solo
questo racconto è uno dei più recenti
ecco una delle cose che mi è successo e
più di recente e da quando faccio
sostituito solo che tali che diciamo che
questa è la disavventura più recente che
mi è capitata ve la racconto oggi allora
il titolo ecco la volta che comprai una
casa in spagna a barcellona non lo so
cosa scrivo nel titolo per una roba del
genere è vero
innanzitutto non è una cagata non mi
sono inventato il non è un click bait
perché ho preso una casa barcellona vi
devo raccontare perché tutto questo è
comunque frutto di una disabile
disavventura incredibile bellissimo
l'avatar del mio compagno di squadra
comunque a parte col dirmi che non vi
spiego tutte le dinamiche del perche ho
preso casali sa che se no chi vince bs
for bio di 8 ore però andiamo subito
preso una casa a barcellona ok ho preso
una casa lì ci abita mio cugino ea
barcellona che mi ha appunto consigliato
visto che stava mentendo un appartamento
si era interessato e ho detto sì quando
tu acquisirà casa acquisti una casa devi
andare all'anzhi di raccordo con tipo
che la sta vendendo ovviamente non è che
entri in casa di uno è il tela contro il
cazzo sentimenti d'accordo col tizio una
volta che siete d'accordo sul prezzo
eccetera per iniziare la trattativa sia
bisogno di un notaio che è un notaio
cos'è il notaio è la persona che vi
sedete a un tavolo mette una firma e
incassa un miliardo di euro e poi
youtubers sono degli sfaticati
ovviamente sto scherzando non me ne
vogliano i notai però porca vacca di
messo una firma 33 mila euro del k
siccome la casa e è appunto in spagna il
notaio e spagnolo quindi io che cosa ho
fatto lettore compro questa casa vado a
vedere la piani comprato niente bisogna
vedere
perché sono non ha senso va da vedere
questa casa basta vederla tutto a posto
va bene poi la premia quindi poi sono
nato un giorno a persona nel giorno dopo
sono tornato ok e quindi questa è stata
la prima volta che sono andato a
barcellona per la casa ok
sottolineamo prima volta che vi siamo
volte al numero uno dovevo andare a
barcellona
un'altra volta ancora per acquistare
definitivamente la casa cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che questa seconda volta
dovevo andare appunto dal notaio per
firmare e dal tipo di pagamento della
casa 15 sarei dovuto andare in totale
due volte a barcellona di cui una per
vederla è una per comprarlo ok arrivo a
casa poi a milano dopo un pò di giorni
mi fanno sapere che il notaio vi fa
sapere che per acquistare una casa lì
non si può effettuare il pagamento
direttamente dall'italia
in che senso no non puoi devi aprire un
conto spagnolo che dior dovevo tornare a
barcellona per aprire un conto solo per
potervi passare i soldi per acquistare
la casa per poi acquistarlo quindi sarei
dovuto andare una volta in più per
aprire un conto è tonica che spiega che
si deve fare così facciamo così sono
tornato a barcellona una seconda volta
sono andato di una banca
buongiorno anzi ora 60 doveva aprire un
conto a chi parquet devo a comprare un
viso piso de mer diviso un appartamento
appartamento pisa va bene va bene va
bene i da c a c dati per da tutti i dati
lasciati alla banca ha bisogno di
tiratori e tutto questo con l'aiuto di
mio cugino perché lo spagnolo mica lo so
apro il conto va bene a posto giorno
dopo me ne torno a casa passano due o
tre giorni mi chiama mio cugino mi fa
glory o una bruttissima notizia e io
dimmi io questa cosa non l'avevo capita
il corso è aperto
però tu devi essere qua per mettere la
firma finale sul conto perché tu cosa
fai vai lì apri conto e non è che si
apre subito come un account
internet no ci mette tipo 24 ore per
aprì per la preside tutto quindi
ritornare lì a fare una firma finale
quindi il conto io ce l'avevo ma non era
aperto era in era lì in bozza e io ma
porca adesso vediamo adesso vediamo
niente alla fine è uscito fuori che dove
sono dovuto andare una terza volta
barcellona completamente a caso stavolta
perché mi bastava rimanere fino al
giorno dopo la volta prima e invece non
l'ho fatto
sono tutto tranne una volta
completamente extra solo per mettere una
firmetta vede il periodi sono andato lì
ho fatto stabilmente sotto nata a casa
c'è vedrai che dici sono andato in corso
como
no sono nata a barcellona ha ceduto
prende un aereo per mettere una firma
c'è una roba orribile
vado lì io la terza volta entriamo
buenos dias odio e resmi lo stronzo che
ha messo per aprire il conto quindi io
ho preso un aereo la mattina e ho preso
secondo il pomeriggio li ho comprati
tutti e due ok
vado lì la mattina nel frattempo era
arrivato il documento spagnolo cosa vuol
dire conto acquisti un immobile in
spagna
loro ti danno una sorta di una sorta di
carta di identità no che si chiama anni
e non è proprio la cartellina però una
specie di carta d'identità no che è un
documento tutti ft spagnolo cioè se tu
ti ferma polizia dai quello se vai all
l'ospedale dai quello per aprire
un'attività dai quella del documento
quello che io in italia ho perso tre
volte vado in banca e tipo mi fa ma sì
sì vedo che è stato rilasciato sono come
un documento di identità
quindi prima io ovvero registrato la
banca col passaporto no perché non
c'avevo quel documento quindi tipo vi fa
quindi adesso siamo obbligati a inserire
il documento
ok perché hai questo documento spagnolo
che è più valido quindi dobbiamo
utilizzare quello per legge va bene
inseriti al documento lo inserisce
dopodiché mi si ferma e niguarda a posto
e io e la firma finale la devo fare o no
che ne avete chiamato per questo che ti
vuoi fà a si è l'unico problema è che
bisogna aspettare che il terminale due
lavori e ci vogliono altre 24 ore
mi scusi ci vogliono altre 24 ore deve
elaborare il documento allora hijo de
puta nova ves che sono dovuto rimanere
un altro giorno quarto 4 quarto giorno
avevo un aero il pomeriggio non l'ho
preso non lo prendi dovevo andare a
giocarmi ricordo che la sera doveva
essere a milano avevo preso appuntamento
coi nirkiop per andare a fare una
partita di calcetto chi elettora inizio
gli ho dato buca perché ero a barcellona
ancora bloccato e ho detto ragazzi sono
qua ha bloccato scusate sono i must a
barcellona perché dovevo firmare per sto
maledettissimo conto è ancora non
riuscivo tra l'altro il tipo mi ha detto
guardi ci vogliono 24 ore ma tra l'altro
non è nemmeno n'è neanche detto che si
sblocchi tra 24 ore magari ce ne
vogliono anche di più quindi io che cosa
ho fatto io non ho preso l'aereo
cioè io non ho più comprato nero detto
aver rimango qua barcellona finché non
prendo questo fottutissimo conto io
rimango qua quindi o piuttosto di venire
da voi ogni tre minuti tutti i giorni
finché non mi aprite sto maledettissimo
conto bancario io rimango a barcellona
quindi io sono rimasto a marciana
l'assenza un aereo di ritorno
poi vado lì il giorno dopo eros dias
sono sempre quello stronzo di prima ciao
guardia posto metta una firma qua che
controlliamo o perfetto abbiamo aperto
finalmente conto anche
anche mio cugino siamo usciti io il mio
cugino dalla banca e abbiamo fatto una
foto come se avessimo vinto i mondiali
questa è la foto questo il mio cugino
non si vede che mio cugino perché non ha
i capelli ma il mio cugino
siamo rimasti molto felici di aver fatto
questa impresa titanica di aprire un
conto è praticamente stavo per fare una
rapina al contrario cioè invece di e tra
i dire questa è una rapina datemi i
soldi dobbiamo farlo noi da dire questa
è una rapina
prendete i miei soldi adesso ti lancio
in faccia sti 50 euro e tutti li prendi
e veloce pure abbiamo finalmente dopo il
quarto giorno aperto il conto bancario
ora questo è successo la settimana
scorsa era darne che è successo tanto
tempo fa perché lo ricevo questa la
disavventura più easy
quindi io la casa a barcellona ed ata
non l'ho neanche presa ancora ci va
ancora devo andare lì per la firma
finale devo andare la settimana però noi
realtà da quando è uscito questo video
lavoro già presa in realtà però in
questo momento mentre lo sto facendo io
ancora non l'ho presa devo andare lì al
coro la terza una quinta volta degli il
terza magari dargli una quinta volta per
fare la firma finale sul documento che
attesta che la casa mia questa sarà la
quinta e spero ultima volta perché basta
cioè non ne posso più questo ragazzi era
e la disavventura su quella volta che
comprai una casa a barcellona quella
volta che comprai data non ancora
comprata ma ormai abbiamo questo titolo
per tutti i video quindi teniamo quello
speriamo che mentre sollecito questo
video incantato incrociando le dita
speriamo vada tutto bene che non mi
dicano riaprire 86 conti bancari o robe
del genere che se non mi ammazzo
e meno male che la barcellona ragazzi
perchè a barcellona voi non sapete ma ci
sono tipo un'oretta e mezza di volo qui
capire neanche troppo pesante se avessi
dovuto compra una casa in giappone ecco
chi sarebbe stato un bel problema è
comunque tutto è bene quel che finisce
non lo so se finisce bene ancora non ho
finito però volevo raccontarvi questa
disavventura a metà sperando che non ci
sia niente di peggio al massimo faccio
una parte 2 di questo video abbiamo
perso sta partita benissimo però di non
perderla casa signori questo era quella
volta che comprai la casa barcellona che
non vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi a che
mai schiacciatela campanellina prima
nella giocati sulle video che escono
eroi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video della ragazza
[Musica]